what do you think is
strengths and weaknesses of Elon Musk
you mentioned Twitter have you paid your
eight dollars I have not paid my dollars
I don't see the point in paying for it I
have no problem paying for services I
use a ton of services I'll try the free
I'll go to the paid
um right now so the way I used to use
the verified feed was I would post a
tweet and then the next day when I you
know review what's going on in my social
media I would look at the replies to the
Tweet which would give me a mix of
replies from verified and unverified
people but then I'd also look at the
verified and see who that are
verified public folks have responded to
me or maybe I want to engage with or
whatever the case may be
there's I don't even understand why I
would look at the verified feed anymore
so I never do because it's random folks
who I don't know when it sort of lost
its utility to me